ich mache jetzt nicht nur Integration
ich kann euch beruhigen in meinem Leben
habe ich auch ein Ausgleich ich chille sehr gerne
chillen wer das nicht kennt ist
ein anderes Wort für rumlungern
und bei uns in Bielefeld ist chillen
eigentlich nur auf Bushaltestellen aufpassen
das ist wirklich wichtiger als man
denkt Leute steigen ein Leute steigen
aus da muss jemand stehen der sich
auskennt bushaltestellenmanagement
extrem gechillt wir haben
mittlerweile sogar eine Schillerstraße
und der Boss auf der Schillerstraße leider nicht
dich der Boss ist Ali und Ali wie kann man den
beschreiben werden Gangster ist aber eigentlich
ein harmloser Bengel und damit ein gefährlichen
Ruf hat sucht er sich immer die krassesten Hobbys
Hobbys auf die man gar nicht kommen würde er hat
sie und er zieht sie auch durch sein Liebling
mittlerweile seit vier Jahren er guckt Polizisten
so lange an bis sie weggucken alle noch die Idee
zu kommen hat eigentlich schon Oscar verdient er
zieht's auch durch es hat ein einziges Mal
nicht geklappt wir waren unterwegs das war
ein heißer Sommertag sein BMW 3 aber auch dabei
Baujahr 93 Seitenspiegel Baujahr 2010 die sind
immer Neuwagen aus aber nie unnötig er hat zum
Beispiel richtig schöne Felgen aber nur rechts
die Fußgänger die das auch sehen können und so
ne und irgendwann standen wir halt in diesem BMW
an der Ampel neben uns hätten Polizeiwagen
an Ali freut sich ja wohl Hobby guckt den
Polizisten an ganz böse damit er endlich
weiterfährt der Polizist kann nicht der
hat rot ne guckt uns ganz normal an Ali wird
richtig sauer guckt ihn wirklich extremst an
ich konnte seine Augen sehen aber ich habe die
Angst gespürt auf einmal Kurbel der Polizist
die Scheibe runter und Ali auch das hat nämlich
eine riesen Überraschung wir hätten Sommer 30
Grad dann ist alle die Scheiben eigentlich
immer oben damit alle denken klimaanlage
ja beide gucken sich an wie ein Western Film
ich denke mir scheiße gleich passiert was
und bevor Ali irgendwas sagen kann
sagt der Polizist ein Döner bitte
das war wirklich also ja noch nie hat jemand
so schnell Ali auf dem Konzept gebracht
für alle war das doch gelaufen der Beifahrer
Polizist kriegt noch einen nach zwei Döner
zum Mitnehmen die richtig sauer ich habe heimlich
gelacht und anstatt einfach den Mund zu halten
sagt alle Ideen sagst du nicht sagen darf ey du
denkst wohl du bist der Einzige mit einer Knarre
ali ist eigentlich schlagfertig an dem Tag
irgendwie nicht ne weiß ich nicht was da los
war der Polizist guckt ihn an sagt nein das
denke ich nicht einmal rechts ranfahren bitte
Ali fährt rechts ran bekommt Panik denkt
er hat wirklich eine Waffe dabei bzw du
hast keine Waffe du hast gelogen stimmt danke
wie bei der steigen aus die beiden Polizisten
auch einer ist fast komplett im Handschuhfach
verschwunden sucht nach der Waffe bis heute
nicht aufgetaucht der andere Polizist statt
hinten mit uns beiden aufgepasst dass wir
nicht weglaufen hat über den BMW gestanden
die Felgen hatte er vorher noch nicht gesehen
am Ende war klar wir haben keine Waffe dabei die
haben uns verabschiedet mit den netten Worten so
Jungs weiterhin angenehm Aufenthalt in Deutschland
wir haben uns gefreut Ali vor allem Ali sagt dem
richtig stolz endlich Stress mit der Polizei sein
Traum wurde wahr ist und familiending wann hat man
zum ersten mal Ärger mit der Polizei ich war sogar
dabei als dein Vater zum ersten Mal Stress mit der
Polizei hatte das war 1997 wir sind mit dem Wagen
losgefahren Ali Beifahrer ich hinten Einkaufen
Alis Vater sieht ein Nachbarn hupt wegen dem Zug
Polizist hat das leider gesehen hat uns angehalten
hat gesagt ja das Hupen als Grußform nett gemeint
ist leider in Deutschland nicht erlaubt zehnmal
verwahrungsgeld reichen vollkommen aus alles Vater
sauer ist angehalten wurde gibt den 20 Markstein
der polizistrat haben Sie vielleicht passend
was macht Vater noch mal und sagt stimmt so
das ist schon